merci Quentin et on va en parler avec
notre invité sur ce plateau pendant
cette suspension de séance Roger carochi
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateur les
républicains premier vice-président du
Sénat un mot sur ces nouvelles tensions
ce matin entre la droite sénatoriale et
la gauche et natale on a l'impression
qu'on va avoir du mal à aller au bout de
cette réforme de retraite au Sénat
clairement la gauche ne veut pas de vote
clairement elle le dit d'ailleurs depuis
le début on a eu tout ce qu'il fallait
des centaines de sous amendements
déposés notamment des rappels au
règlement incessants des explications de
vote qui n'en finissaient pas des
amendements identiques déposés à
l'infini bon clairement la gauche ne
veut pas voter
je considère que c'est un tort c'est un
tort pas seulement pour la gauche quel
droit de s'exprimer et qui s'exprime
d'ailleurs largement elle a utilisé plus
de 90% du temps de débat depuis 8 jours
mais le Sénat est fait pour voter
l'Assemblée nationale est faite pour
voter on est passé pour discuter à
l'infini du sexe des anges ou être des
groupes de parole nous sommes là pour
faire la loi et nous avons d'ailleurs
voté un certain nombre d'amendements
quand même ces derniers jours qui sont
des apports sur les carrières longues
sur l'emploi des seniors sur
l'invalidité on a fait le boulot mais
maintenant on voit bien que la gauche va
à nouveau bloquer on dit
les sous amendements qui viennent d'être
déposés sur l'abonnement priorité
faire le travail pour améliorer les
textes la situation de blocage est un
sens le gouvernement qui pourrait
utiliser ce vote bloqué sur cette
réforme des retraites au Sénat
rappelez-nous concrètement qu'est-ce que
ça signifierait si le gouvernement dit à
Linéa enfin article 44 lignée A3 ça veut
dire qu'il fait voter de manière bloquée
en un seul vote sur les articles en
acceptant seulement les Allemands que le
gouvernement accepte c'est-à-dire pas
les amendements votés par le Sénat mais
seulement les amendements que lui
accepte ce qui est quand même une
réduction forte du pouvoir du Parlement
mais je rappelle que pour la loi
Touraine pendant le gouvernement
socialiste en 2013 le gouvernement
socialiste avait fait le vote bloqué
pour la deuxième lecture de la réforme
Touraine à l'Assemblée nationale donc
effectivement malheureusement c'est une
pratique possible pour écarter le débat
parlementaire et le fait que la gauche
fasse de l'obstruction conduit à cela
donc selon vous le gouvernement
que le blocage continue que la gauche
continue ce blocage et il ne peut pas y
avoir de vote dimanche soir soit la
gauche a dit bon allez stoppe on arrête
tout en fait un vrai débat quasiment
soir et on va au vote et là ça peut se
passer sereinement si ça n'est pas le
cas si le gouvernement veut un vote et
bien naturellement il passera par le 44
3 ce que dit la gauche sénatoriale c'est
que le droit d'amendement des sénateurs
et un peu piétiner par la droite
seatoriale c'est un droit d'amendement
constitutionnel et que est-ce que ça
peut fragiliser et bien cette réforme de
retraite sur la le Constitutionnel parce
que le Conseil constitutionnel apprécie
en premier lieu les tentatives de
blocage et lorsqu'il y a blocage
lorsqu'il y a effectivement une
tentative d'empêcher le Parlement de
voter le Conseil constitutionnel en
prend vraiment compte et là quand tu
verras la masse de rappel au règlement
la masse de la maman identique les
centaines de sous-amendements déposés
une huit amont le Conseil
constitutionnel dire il y avait
obstruction et par conséquent les moyens
du règlement ou de la Constitution
devaient être mise en place ce que
disent les sénateurs de gauche c'est que
ce n'est pas normal que la Commission
refuse d'examiner certains amendements
qui sont déposés non mais si vous
déposez à tout moment dans la nuit ou
après l'ouverture de la discussion
générale des sous amendes vous pouvez
plus déposer amendement des sous
amendements clairement la Commission
peut pas suivre et donc ça n'est qu'une
tentative d'empêcher le débat donc dans
ces conditions malheureusement je ne
sais pas comment ça va se passer si le
gouvernement n'utilise pas dans d'autres
armes je doute que l'on arrive au vote
sauf si la gauche se ressaisissant
disait nous nous voulons vraiment dans
les trois jours qui viennent débattre
sur un certain nombre d'amendements
forts pour nous auquel cas la discussion
est possible et si c'est pas le cas et
si c'est juste pour faire multiplier des
rappels au règlement des sous
amendements et tout autant dire que le
Sénat ne fait pas son travail René Paul
Savary a parlé hier soir d'un accord
qu'il y avait entre les présidents de
groupe à droite et à gauche pour aller
au bout de cette réforme des retraites
je n'en sais rien moi j'étais pas dans
cette réunion mais clairement on a été
extrêmement
gentleman si je puis dire à l'égard des
groupes de gauche sur ce qu'ils ont
demandé pour le 7 mars sur l'article 7
et tout visiblement ça ne sert pas à
grand chose la confrontation est
malheureusement devenue la règle au
Sénat ce qui n'était pas l'habitude une
dernière question Roger carotic sur le
fond quand même de ce qui a été discuté
ce matin il y avait plutôt un accord
entre les ceintures de gauche et les
sénateurs de droite pour voter un
amendement sur les travailleurs déclarés
en incapacité permanente et pour qu'il
puisse partir à 60 ans à la retraite
c'est dommage que les débats ait tourné
vinaigre bah oui moi j'ai des fendu je
me suis levé pour défendre cette
amendement et demander au gouvernement
de ne pas s'y opposer parce que ça me
paraît essentiel c'est ça le rôle du
Sénat c'est d'apporter des améliorations
c'est de penser aux gens pas seulement
aux rivalités politiciennes
malheureusement avant même le vote de
cet amendement on a sombré dans les
rivalités merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'être venu sur le plateau de Public
Sénat pendant cette suspension de séance
on va retrouver Quentin